hi guys so I've graduated I went to
university for three years and a few
days ago I spent my night in London
getting my medal well it's not actually
your diploma it's just a little piece of
paper that says follow us on social
media and stay in touch but I will get
my diploma like sent me I have graduated
and yeah now I'm back home and I really
want to do those videos
unlike my experience of University and
whether you should go and what what was
good about it what maybe wasn't so good
about it everything but I just haven't
been in the mood because post-grad Blues
are really a thing and I just wasn't
gonna like do a video at all for a
little bit but then I realize while I've
been unpacking my stuff and you know
moving and and everything else what's
helped me just not feel as lonely I
guess
is just hearing people ramble on YouTube
and that's what YouTube's all about
right so I was like okay maybe I can
help other people going through this
because of course it is a very real
thing like you you graduate and it's
like amazing and then you you're with
your friends you like thank God it's
over all the hard work you know paid off
and and we graduated and we got this
thing and this amazing and then suddenly
you're back at home or that's the case
of most people and you're not living
with the friends that you've been with
for the past 2 or 3 years like
everything that you've come to know I
mean your sleeping schedule like
everything is so out of whack and then
you move back with your family and
you're like how how how do I be what is
what is my thing so today I'm just gonna
ramble to you a bit I mean I don't even
have internet right now so I'm gonna try
and find somewhere
upload this but everything just seems a
bit like out of whack at the moment and
that's okay I wanted to kind of just
chat through my feelings I try not to
ramble too much because you know I still
got stuff to do but um yeah University
was amazing I mean it was it was a
little bit different for me because I
was working before I went to uni so I'm
actually coming home after five years of
living away because I was working for
two years before I went to uni in London
so it's so frickin strange but I've got
to say University is an experience that
I know I won't get again and it honestly
is once-in-a-lifetime and that's what
people would tell me and that's why I
decided to go and I'm glad that I did
I'm so glad that I did I mean that
people that I met are amazing and it's
so weird not to live with them it's so
we're not just like knock on my door or
hear their music blasting or you know
just go to the kitchen and there's
there's people there and it's so strange
I mean I'm someone who doesn't like
change anyway so to be back here like
without them I'm just like haha I don't
want I want a hug from my housemate um
ya know I like I feel so blessed to have
known them and then I guess like when
you come home from being away for so
long it's so weird because every other
time you've come home you know that
you're not staying you just spend time
with your friends spend time with your
family and then then you're off again
and when you're in uni you're constantly
missing your home and your your mom
making you cups of tea and coffee and
you know your friends like at home and
your home life and then you come home
after grad and you realize oh no no no
no no I miss uni it's so annoying
because he always bought what we can't
have but it's it's gonna be difficult
the cards obviously you're worried about
your future where you gonna go next
that is a question that everyone will
ask you and then they say you know we
don't worry about it too much because
you need to relax and you know you've
been stressed out a lot and that's true
as well
I mean life goes on your future happens
but also I think it's it's very
important to realize how you're feeling
in this moment and you know it's not
it's not an easy transition to make you
come home and all of I guess your past
kind of resurfaces past troubles or pass
worries and past stresses that you kind
of forgot about when you were worrying
about your uni staff and your deadlines
and all this stuff that kind of
resurfaces and you're like well I
totally forgot that this is the thing um
so I guess that's that's quite hard to
come to terms with and work around
because when you're in university the
stress is real but it's also I guess you
can kind of take control of it like it's
it's up to you whether you are gonna
reach this deadline and get your grades
and everything else but then you know
real life stress and home life stress
that that stuff this o on a DIF eleven
oh god I don't know where I'm going with
this and my battery and my camera is
dying so I actually need to stop and I
don't even know if this is worth an
upload now but look after yourself when
you get home from uni my plan is to sell
out a list of what I want to do over the
summer I want to be here by this point I
don't want to be staying with my family
for years and years and years it's fine
if you want to I don't and I know I
don't so I need to figure out steps on
how I'm going to get where I want to get
in the future build up your portfolio
obviously look for jobs and things like
that but also look after yourself and
just realize that yes your home and yes
it's stressful yes you've got to think
about the future but at the same time
you're finally back with your
parents you're finally back at home with
your home friends and the people that
you are missing when you're in
university and you're bound to miss
those people in university but now
you're finally back with people at home
and this is time for you to relax as
well and yes I'm saying this to myself
too
this is one of the reasons why I wanted
to do this video it's just it's okay now
you can relax deadlines are over well
done you did it allow yourself time to
just chill and enjoy everything that
your home life has to offer you from me
it's the C and then and it's the summer
and that's the best thing so I can enjoy
the C I can place music I can be a bit
more chilled and once I get myself into
some sort of structure I can start
uploading regularly I can start looking
for for proper jobs again or carry on my
freelance stuff and see how that goes so
anyway apologies for this random video
hopefully you like the rambles anyway
hopefully you can relate maybe and if
you can't then if you know anyone who's
just graduated or if you're about to
graduate or know someone who's just
about to then it's okay you you've got
this and it's okay feeling sad it's all
an emotion you had a great time more
times to come in the future also don't
let people go because I know I'm not
going to you know who you are and I'm
gonna let you go I'm gonna do everything
in my power to just stay in touch with
everyone that made a remarkable
difference in my life and that includes
in my uni life because in those three
years it's three years in my long time
but you form such a close friendship
with these people because they had
literally become your second family and
yeah it just means everything but take
some time for you don't feel you have to
jump in with a hold of the scary future
stuff I'm going through it too so if you
want to put in the comments below how
you're feeling if you have any questions
about university or about how I'm going
to pursue my life in the future ask them
in the comments below I will be doing a
much better structured video about my
uni experience when I feel a little bit
more settled in myself but anyway as
always thank you so much for your
support I will probably show you some
more my hometown soon as well and maybe
even my new bedroom for the next few
months so yeah have a lovely day or
evening take care of yourself that's the
main thing and I'll do it too how do if
you do okay
deal deal so wait we got this just keep
saying and it will be true we got this
we got this we got this oh I hate
unpacking